yes government has broken the hearts
part the people of Los Angeles we're
expecting the police they promised to
evict us and that's what we expect to
happen occupy la was raided November
30th 2011 just after midnight by 1400
police officers police in riot gear
first through the doors inside Los
Angeles City Hall flooding the park
surrounding the building LAPD made over
200 arrests and begun to dismantle the
camp while officers pushed back the
crowd assembled in the street nowhere to
go eventually Rusty's were taken away in
buses and cooked off-site
the LAPD restricted media heavily during
the raid to those approved by the
Department making the operation they
plant run smoothly and prompting mayor
Antonio varicosities you a statement
saying that the city took a measured
approach while clothes in the park
occupier said to us previously that rate
or no raid the movement isn't over this
occupy movement is here to stay it's a
movement not on individual protest
people have this misconception of it
being in small divided localities it's
in 600 locality or in the country and
thousands of 1000 to the ground and
strong this affects everyone that's what
people need to realize people have tried
to criticize this movement as being
liberal as being run independence being
fringes just being a flash in the pan
that's not true this is a movement that
affects everyone in America they could
shut us down all they want the movements
still there you can shut down this book
and grunt all they're doing is like
we're going to take backup art you know
what you just proved to us that you
stomped on the right to assembly and
freedom of speech you just took that
away from us as a [ __ ] movement will
win BAM there you go for reason TV I'm
Paul Dietrich